live in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
Daniel and Laura are with us hey guys
how are ya whywould how are you welcome
welcome where are you from
we're from Highland California right
next to San Bernardino oh welcome to
Nashville that's a bit of a haul yes
cross the continent to do a debt-free
scream I love it how much have you paid
off $90,000 Wow and how long did that
take 59 months just shy of our five-year
anniversary very cool and your range of
income during those years we started
about it 60,000 and then we were about
115 right now
Wow great job so what do you guys do for
a living we're both music teachers Oh
fun good so 59 months six years are five
years you said your five year
anniversary of being married mm-hmm oh
so that's what started this whole thing
yeah we actually started when we were in
premarital counseling so okay so the
pastor said I get your act together on
money are you gonna kill each other yeah
and plus he has a wife who said I didn't
want to get married with a finance story
so I was the nerd and I kind of
intimidated him a little bit because we
sat down as part of our pretty marriage
talking and I said you know how much
debt do you have and he got scared and
so one of the things that I really came
to love and respect about Daniel was
that in that dating and engage time he
stepped aside and learned how to save
and learn how to budget and so I knew
when he presented that ring that not
only was he showing his love for me but
just really the the process of being
able to grow together I think it was
love because truthfully Laura you're not
that intimidating you're way too sweet
to be intimidated the intimidation is
over here on this desk
go Daniel ding-ding ma'am don't well
done well done
so I'm guessing Daniel this was a lot of
your dad
yes actually um I decided to go to a
private school for music and that
combined with car and credit cards kind
of added up a little bit so uh so the
ninety was all you know how much were
you in for oh I don't remember the exact
breakdown because we knew right away
that it wasn't one it was both of our
dads very sweet but you're lying how I
don't remember even though I'm the nerd
I don't remember the exact like twenty
or so probably I was probably the twenty
okay very good so the good news is is
that on to music teacher salaries you
start low and you just build your
careers here obviously your incomes have
gone up congratulations and Ashley Dave
we're in California where we're at
there's a lot of back and forth each
year based on contracts so there were
times when we were one or both of us was
unemployed during that five year span
oh wow so we've we've had to be very
careful in that process of even though
it looked like we had salary we had
times of us both not having a job and
that was a little intimidating but
because we knew how to to budget and set
money aside for those tough times that's
enough to make you want to open a music
school that you own your own thing yeah
well congratulations you two
how does it feel after fifty nine months
to be completely free oh it's it's very
very it relieves a lot of stress yeah
and I have to share a part of our story
too is we actually had it gained a lot
of weight and we're just in the process
we ended up losing between the two of us
about two hundred and fifty pounds
good yeah so we know it's not just a
Backstreet Boy yes well no no not each
oh well I'll do my manly
a quarter yeah yeah way to go you two
yes Wow you've changed everything the
before-and-after picture of the wallet
the before and after picture personally
Wow yep very cool you guys are winning
on every front
that's kangri well-disciplined does
baguette discipline they say and it does
when you learn to control one area of
your life it teaches you that you can do
what they call self control and then
you're doing that and congratulations
well I'm very proud of you too very well
done you are heroes very good and you're
you got a real story to tell your
student two stories to tell your
students there that are about about the
you know the power of discipline and no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
it's very very well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is in it's difficult because there
are moments where you don't want to do
it and someone had said something to me
once she said choose again and so the
key is just choosing choosing again and
again and again and then of course of
course the budget budget helps but we
knew and that's you know it even goes
for a marriage and the tough days of
just choosing again you know choose is
that that's a really good line because I
just indicates that you have power over
your choices you're not a victim I can
choose all right I choose I'm not gonna
do that anymore
I choose I'm gonna do that now that's
that's a good that's really good I like
that
very well done all right Daniel and
Laura San Bernardino California 90,000
bucks paid off in five years of marriage
making 62 115 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
we're dead
well done man that's how you do it right
there Wow
it's a lot of discipline five years
they've been doing that stuff pretty
incredible hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind